Congratulations, if
you've made it this far.
You've learned so
much about mapping, satellite views,
drawing on a map, markers, custom pins,
Street View, and a whole lot more.
It's been a lot of material covering
a lot of territory, pun fully intended.
And, I hope you've been inspired to
think about how you could make your app
better by using Rich Mapping.
Or indeed, maybe you have an idea for an
app that could be built around Mapping.
Think about what you can do, if you
combine it with Location Services and
other Google APIs.
With that, I'll sign off in the hope
that you've really enjoyed this course.
I look forward to seeing
what you can do with Maps
in your future Android applications.